let's get some analysis now from George
Washington University Law Professor
Jonathan Turley good evening sir
thanks Mike let's start with the
indictments was that a warning shot
fired by the US government at Moscow
well it was quite a shot I don't know if
it was a warning or below the waterline
it's clearly if you read between the
lines it's clearly saying that this was
a Russian government operation it didn't
spontaneously happen that you have
dozens of people involved in a hacking
operation with elaborate disguising zuv
the their groups their identities it's
suggesting that I think this is a
government operation I now that points
to Vladimir Putin what's interesting is
that it doesn't really point to Donald
Trump that manure that is likely to be
cited in this whole story and that is
unwitting that is the adjective
unwitting appears in the indictment to
describe Trump officials who had
contacts with these Russians they say
that they didn't know that they were
Russians and but what's fascinating is
that it doesn't suggest that they have
evidence of collusion it's in and this
was brought out by Rosen sting obviously
we have that soundbite let's go to it if
we can there is no allegation in this
indictment that any American was a
knowing participant in this illegal
activity there is no allegation in the
indictment that the charge conduct
altered the outcome of the 2016 election
so your analysis at that point well you
know that's what's fascinating it's been
a year with multiple plea agreements a
lot of testimony a lot of interviews and
they're saying that they still don't
have any evidence of any knowing
engagement the Russians involved in this
effort that has to be good news to the
Trump White House it's also notable that
the the meeting and Trump Tower is in
mentioned you know they knew those were
Russians but if they were part of this
effort there would be some reference
there their identity was clear and yet
that is also not mentioned is some of
this basically saying to the folks
behind us on Capitol Hill and around the
country that wants some answers about
this and want some action taken about
what happened to our election in 2016
that serious people are on the case
and taking steps to do it to address us
I think it does I think that what
there's a there's a truth that comes out
of this that this makes more sense than
a narratives that everyone's been
throwing around and conspiracies this
began in 2014 began before the
presidential election the Russians were
taking targets of opportunity and they
were shooting at everybody in the
election but they were certainly working
more against Hillary Clinton but what it
does show is that they did a really
quite impressive job in finding this
cyber trail to these individuals and
this is not over I mean these are
individuals that are going to have
serious problems because they've been
tagged let's switch gears to the
devastating story parkland Florida the
FBI says it got a warning drop the ball
your reaction to that you know I don't
agree with Governor Scott the director a
should should resign I don't think that
that's that's in any way responsive I
know there's no indication that he had a
direct involvement in this we need
people to find out the truth to this but
there's a serious problem you can't tell
people see something say something if
the next line is do nothing you know
it's it's it really undermines what the
FBI has been working for years to try to
get people to do so there has to be some
accountability here and some really
explanation because when you when you
read the level of detail that was given
to the FBI it's breathtaking that anyone
on the other side of that phone wouldn't
go oh my god and immediately start to
rally people to get on this it sounds
like it just went into a drawer was left
there here's the explanation from the
FBI let's take a listen provided
information about Nicholas Cruz
and the potential of him becoming a
school shooter under normal protocol
this information should have been
provided to the Miami field office
they're appropriate investigative steps
would have been taken
the FBI has determined that protocol was
not followed you've been around this
town a long time should somebody go for
this quite frankly I think someone
should be fired for this is not ray but
we have to find out who was who was
responsible the FBI has been accused of
not sharing information in the past with
local authorities that's a big gripe
that you hear from a lot of prosecutors
investigators but this one is far far
more serious nobody receiving that
information could just view this as one
more call about some you know some kid
saying stupid things
this was detailed and this was eminent
festerly thanks Mike thanks for your
time and analysis we appreciate it